my heart was breaking for you because
you're really honest about the
horrible reviews you got when you
started as the anchor for weekend update
it made me think i was a bad human
right i know that's crazy to say no it
actually made me
feel like i was not a good person i
really felt bad about
who i was because no one had ever had
any judgment of
me before and then suddenly everyone did
and it felt really
rough were you embarrassed in front of
the other cast members like here's all
my friends and now
oh my god i can't even look them in the
eye yes it was i i i
say in the book is that it's like if you
worked at mcdonald's
and one day you come in and you're like
i'm ronald mcdonald
and i'm going to be ronald mcdonald and
everyone else who works at the
mcdonald's is like why is this guy
ronald mcdonald
and then you're terrified of blowing
everything of like being a bad ronald
and also losing your regular job at
mcdonald's that is the fear you have of
stepping forward like that
i had such deep deep deep like anxiety
like drinking before shows like
because i i felt like i was losing my
whole identity like my whole identity
that i had built up for whatever it was
ten years at the show
i thought i was going to lose everything
and and then just be like
be done and uh you know that all my best
friends were there at the show and and
then suddenly
people aren't talking to you is that
really true people stop
talking to you because you know in that
show business way
yes like people that you used to just
you saw like a look from them in the
hallway
where you were like oh [ __ ] like this is
not
you know people i worked with
recommended
people to replace me to me wow
i mean you know but but but in all
seriousness very burned in my memory
because i was like
[ __ ] you but they really they were like
you know who might be good i was like
what well you know to be a comedian you
build up a certain swagger
you know you need it even if it's all
[ __ ] the double problem was
i didn't have that swagger i did not
have a confidence at this
specific thing when i started i think
people watching me
thought i was almost overconfident that
i had like a smugness
like i deserve this that was that i
didn't i never thought about
what is what am i projecting what how do
i come across to people because i never
had to before
so it was a combination of seeming
overconfident and
feeling no confidence at all when you're
in a crisis like that do you turn to
like someone like tina fey
who hosted the news and said i'm sinking
here no
because you're too embarrassed one of
the things that was a turning point bill
murray came by the offices one time and
he was
really encouraging to me and shay he
came by one night and he was kind of
like there's something there
like that you guys got something there
that you can keep working on but like
there's something there
but that meant a lot because obviously i
love him and it was like a
it just the fact that he was we were
even on his radar or he
saw something felt great